some say that
scp-2102 was a mistake an abomination
created by an accident of medical
science maybe those people are right
maybe there's much more to it than that
either way they don't know the full
story how could they they weren't there
they weren't there all the way back in
1972
but dr pavel zhukol was the earliest
moments the events that directly
preceded
scp-2102's creation began on march 2nd
the wind was carrying an unforgiving
freezing bite with it as zookal made his
way to the institute of experimental
medicine zizov in czechoslovakia with
the cold war between the ussr and the
united states underway there was already
an air of secrecy on both sides
espionage and intelligence gathering
operations were rampant bringing with
them paranoia and distrust there was no
way of knowing if someone was a double
agent leaking information to the west
but while the governments of russia
america and their various respective
allies and enemies scrambled for control
and amassed obscene quantities of
nuclear arms in secret there were even
more cogs turning hidden in the deepest
darkest shadows the scp foundation's
long-standing rivalry with various other
groups of interest was well known among
any with a high enough security
clearance most of these groups were
radicals or outliers despite possessing
knowledge of anomalies or even being
directly linked to them a lot of gois
were independent of any world government
but for decades the foundation had been
aware of a directly competing
establishment effectively a parallel of
their own organization on the other side
of the globe they were known as gru
division p a ussr equivalent of the scp
foundation themselves it is unclear
based on what was recovered from dr
zhukal's personal diary if he had been
directly scouted by gru division p for
their project in czechoslovakia given
the air of secrecy engulfing the ussr at
the time it is possible that pavel
himself had no inclination that division
p was even involved in the project due
to take place at the institute of
experimental medicine he might have
suspected but with no way of knowing for
sure similarly there was no way zukal
could have known where the project would
lead what he would have a hand in
creating the initial few weeks after his
arrival at the institute were rocky to
say the least zukal along with a team of
scientists and technicians working on
orders direct from moscow had to contend
with unreliable equipment and difficulty
getting electricity to power the project
eventually after clearing those initial
hurdles testing could begin but what was
the goal of this mysterious project well
through zocal gru division p and the
kremlin were chasing something the
scientific world has been trying to
accomplish for decades something that
could change the very landscape of not
only the cold war but the entirety of
modern medicine the secrets of cellular
regeneration unlocking that would in
theory enable them to create the world's
very first unkillable super soldier and
hey it definitely wouldn't be the
craziest secret operation carried out by
a world superpower during the cold war
the cia spent millions turning a cat
into a listening device and training it
to infiltrate enemy headquarters this
so-called acoustic kitty was struck and
killed by a random van during its first
mission compared to that a cell
regenerating super soldier was
positively sensible with a worldwide
nuclear arms race already underway
perhaps the project's ultimate goal was
to produce an entire army of these
self-regenerating troops with something
like that in their hands the ussr would
have the manpower to reinforce their
nuclear arsenal and potentially even
soldiers capable of surviving and
healing from the effects of an atomic
blast on the 5th of may
1972 the first of the project's human
test subjects began to show promising
results they underwent physical trauma
at the hands of zukal and the other
scientists only for their bodies to
react much faster than the ordinary
healing process would allow rapid
clotting took place in the affected
areas preventing the subjects from
bleeding out however this quickly went
awry the clots turned into severe
lesions realizing this had occurred
thanks to macaulay one of the other
project scientists administering too
much neodymium zookal chastised his
colleague vowing him to drag him to
moscow personally if another mistake
like that ever took place again
unfortunately by the last few days of
june dr zhukal and his team were no
closer to success every subject that
underwent testing succumbed to the same
necrosis reducing the amount of
neodymium had only made the reaction
worse something pavel couldn't allow
mikali to know without the risk of it
being held over his head for the
remainder of the project in every
instance the doctors were able to
trigger rapid cell division 50 times
faster than that which occurs in the
ordinary healing process of human beings
but the biggest drawback was that this
division would quickly become
uncontrollable it was creating enough
new matter on a cellular level that it
would choke each test subject in its own
excess waste as you might expect dr
zhukal noted this in his diary that this
process wasn't a pretty sight come
mid-august 1972
the project scientists decided they
needed a test subject with more
resilience than the average person and a
suitable candidate was provided he was a
counter-revolutionary who had been
sentenced to 15 years in a uranium mine
as a punishment detail despite such an
extended period of time under the harsh
conditions of the mine and the close
proximity to a radioactive element such
as uranium the man managed to survive
unscathed upon closer examination this
new guinea pig referred to as x-16 had a
rate of healing twice as fast as that of
an average man perhaps it was a random
genetic abnormality that made x-16 this
way or maybe it was a result of his
extensive time in the uranium mines
either way it made him the perfect new
subject for zukal's experiments
initially subject x-16's preliminary
testing results looked promising the
wound healing process was actually
taking place now instead of resulting in
necrosis or aborting it as it had with
the earlier experiments in fact dr
zhukov seemed to think x-16 was healing
almost too quickly but nevertheless
testing continued although not without a
different type of problem the
questionable morality of what they were
doing began to set in for paval causing
him nights of endless tossing and
turning unable to sleep as he reflected
on what he'd done x-16 had managed to
survive for much longer than the earlier
test subjects but it was clear that the
torture this man had to endure was
exacting a heavy toll every day the
doctors would lacerate him time and time
again recording the results and every
day he survived only for the cycle to
begin again the next day for his own
part zukul was conflicted on the one
hand the results of the testing were
proving successful lasting far longer
and working far more effectively than
they had in the past and yet on the
other it came at the cost of one man's
continued suffering to make matters
worse pavel had no way of voicing his
concerns to any of his team any
questioning of his orders or the
project's methods would have been viewed
by gru division p and the kgb as
sedition and treason earning the good
doctor a one-way ticket to a gulag or if
he was lucky a clean shot to the back of
the head from an agent's pistol often
morality is sacrifice for the greater
good in the pursuit of the advancement
of science or a nation's goals but now
that the project was showing results
with x-16 now that it was real what they
were doing still weighed heavily on dr
zhukov's conscience then on october 15
1972 the final piece of the puzzle
seemed to become clear by introducing
the correct amount of stabilizing agent
into the serum they had concocted zukal
and his team had perfected the
composition upon administering this
newly completed version of the solution
the doctor noted in his diary that
subject x-16 was responding well at
least medically the subject was
responding well it was clear that the
continuous experimentation he had been
subjected to was causing uncooperative
behavior in x-16 but so close to the
cusp of achieving the project's goals dr
zhukol was quick to cast aside his
previous doubts about the ethics of
their methods they were so close to
victory so close to the project being
over that it no longer mattered how
cooperative x-16 was being but two weeks
and four days later just as the project
was nearing its end goal disaster struck
mu dr elena orakova was one of the
scientists on zhukov's team who had
primarily helped when examining the
early cell divisions those that were
leading to necrosis and causing test
subjects to produce too much excessive
genetic material elena had made a
startling discovery and immediately
brought it to dr zhukal in a distraught
show of panic the cell samples they had
used to test their serum were now
gaining mass seemingly from nowhere just
like the earlier experiments the effects
were working almost too well causing an
overabundance of cellular regeneration
to the point where the cells couldn't
stop producing masses of waste genetic
material when zookal brought elena's
findings to dr sizlard and one georgie t
fedinko the project heads assigned by
division p they were quick to disregard
it as an error determining to press on
with the project to meet their deadline
over the course of the following weeks
up to late november zukal was trying to
determine what was causing this change
it was clear that unless he and elena
could resolve the issues with the serum
subject x-16 would be a total failure
but time was running out with their
superiors at gru division p and the
kremlin expecting results by early
december under untold amounts of
pressure and subsequent stress dr paval
zukal found himself losing time
unable to sleep to the point where he
was drifting off whenever he was on the
verge of a breakthrough by the end elena
was the only member of the team trying
to help him methodically figure out what
had gone wrong the deadline for the
project arrived on december 2nd 1972.
pavel didn't sleep all night leading up
to it knowing he would have to present a
functioning super soldier to gru
division p in the best case he was
risking being accused of negligent
failure forced to restart the project
from scratch making his months of hard
work redundant but worst case scenario
zookal could be charged with treason for
having not completed the task he was
selected for on the 2nd of december he
wrote i really don't know which is
better
tomorrow is a day too nobody knows if dr
pavel zoukal lived to see that tomorrow
his final diary entry was made on the
day
scp-2102 was born for months the scp
foundation had operatives embedded
within the czechoslovakian government as
part of innumerable cold war espionage
gathering efforts during that time their
agents had gathered enough intelligence
to make the foundation aware of a gru
division p project based at the
institute of experimental medicine and
that the scientists there were looking
to unlock the secret of rapid cellular
regeneration someone possibly even one
of zoukal's team had managed to
infiltrate the project and add leaked
documents to the scp foundation
explaining what was going on in
czechoslovakia the plan was that the
foundation would move in in secret of
course to extract and contain test
subject x-16 in january of 1973
that day would never come to fruition
though on the 2nd of december only a
month before they had planned to act the
foundation became aware of a catastrophe
occurring at the institute of
experimental medicine one of their
agents in czechoslovakia alerted them to
a disturbance that had caused civilians
and scientists alike to run from the
institute in fear for their lives
something had gotten loose and the
foundation had to act fast luckily a
reconnaissance team was stationed in
eastern europe members of various mobile
task forces who had been spying on gru
division p and the rest of the ussr
moving quickly the recon team was
deployed to czechoslovakia led by a
field commander named merrick they were
given the objective to determine the
cause of the situation and if possible
recover its anomalous source merrick and
the recon team arrived on site to the
institute's grounds the entrance to the
bunker which had been housing the
project was left wide open with not a
soul in sight as the team progressed
further merrick couldn't help but notice
a pungent smell permeating the labs and
offices that they passed foundation
command urged their operatives to
proceed cautiously and recover any
paperwork they could among the
logistical documents was a diary
belonging to one of the scientists
although the name paval zukal on the
cover was no longer legible forever lost
the further he and the other mtf agents
progressed the worse the smell got they
located an elevator deciding to take it
down to the lower levels of the bunker
one by one the team filed in merrick
radio in command command any seismic
activity in the area he asked uh not
that we know of merrick came the
foundation's reply why i
i think i just felt something move down
there the elevator had barely descended
to foot before it hit something stopping
in an instant as merrick tried once
again to contact foundation command that
same something came tearing through the
elevator floor over the radio the scp
foundation were treated to a cacophony
of screeching tearing metal along with
the screams of their own men what
merrick and his team had encountered may
have once been a man perhaps someone
subjected to cruelty and torture but now
all they saw was an amorphous flushing
mass immediately the recon team opened
fire engaging what they assumed was a
raging monster it probably never
occurred to them that they might have
just wanted to be free after years of
imprisonment followed by months of
horrendous experiments minutes later
merrick was able to get in contact with
command again locked in a heated battle
with the entity but every round fired
every shot their guns landed nothing was
having any effect whenever merrick dealt
damage to the creature part of it seemed
to grow faster and faster each time
their guns were useless unable to stop
the expanding monstrous test subject
even grenades thrown by the mtf
operatives causing multiple explosions
did little to stop the entity in its
tracks listening in over the radio
knowing they had few options left the
scp foundation dispatched a pair of f4
phantoms long-range supersonic fighter
jets equipped with a payload of m47a1
napalm incendiary bombs with american
his men almost on the ropes command
issued an order to retreat they fled the
bunker only to feel the ground shake
beneath their feet the monster had
breached the top soil still coming after
them jones one of the foundation's
agents was pulled under the encroaching
shapeless mass crushed to death as it
continued its pursuit utterly horrified
at the sight and speed of the creature
merrick started begging command over the
radio to get its fighter jets to the
scene six minutes later the sound of
twin turbine engines shot through the
air followed by the whistle of bombs
careening down towards the ground in a
second merrick his team and the creature
were engulfed in a fiery explosion the
heat proving enough to cauterize the
fleshy abomination's expanding tissue
ever since december 1972 the entity now
designated as
scp-2102 has been housed at site 122
contained by the scp foundation they
keep it in a modified cell restrained at
all times with its hands and feet and
padded sleeves this is done in order to
prevent the risk of injury either
accidental or intentional given both
scp-2102's anomalous properties and its
self-destructive tendencies its body is
covered in scars both from its previous
escape attempts back when it was known
as subject x-16 and from burns from the
f4 phantom's napalm payload these
particular injuries seared the entity's
ears mouth and eyes closed rendering it
deaf mute and blind if
scp-2102 ever suffers any form of
external injury its anomalous properties
will trigger the creature as you might
have guessed possessed an advanced form
of cellular healing able to regenerate
from all wounds inflicted on it however
the process was never perfected it still
works too well so well that scp-2102
cells don't know when to stop instead
they continue producing bodily tissue
expanding its mass into every available
space without a halt the process can be
slowed if an obstacle is introduced
boxing in the exponentially growing
tissue however any object or person in
its path is eventually crushed under the
mounting pressure at present the
foundation still has no idea how much
scp-2102's tissue could expand
potentially even posing a risk to the
entire world if left unchecked there is
only one surefire way to stop the
creature's healing it can only be halted
by cauterizing the open wound with
intense heat it's literally a surefire
solution
scp-2102 is a result of the good dr
zhukov's work combined with his and gru
division p's willingness to put aside
their morality they didn't create an
undying regenerating super soldier for
the ussr as they had intended instead
all they accomplished was turning a
tortured man into a monster an
abomination endlessly tormented by the
experiments performed on him not quite
as useful on the battlefield is it now
go check out scp-049 the plague doctor
and scp-847 the mannequin for more
stories of medically macabre
monstrosities sure to make your blood
run cold